aufsicht will dass sie nicht vom könnte
team süd das sind christina aus russland
jonas aus norwegen und nasse aus ägypten
ihre reise startet in den alpen
hier kommt aufgabe nummer eins sucht die
wetterberichte aus faz bild sz und
garmischer heraus
was bedeuten bloß diese abkürzungen ich
glaube wir müssen diese vier zeitungen
kaufen
stimmt bild sz faz und garmischer sind
abkürzungen für vier deutsche zeitungen
doch wofür brauchen sie die
wetterberichte bringt die berichte zu
der wetterstation die sich hier befindet
und wo geht's hin
zum glück müssen die drei nicht auf den
höchsten berg laufen in garmisch
partenkirchen fährt die zugspitzbahn ab
muss das team umsteigen nach dem zug
geht es weiter mit der seilbahn richtung
gipfel
dort oben liegt das ganze jahr über
schnee
endstation zugspitzgipfel laut gps gerät
sind es jetzt nur noch wenige meter bis
zum ziel
christina jonas und nasa sind jetzt auf
2962 meter und wem ist es hier oben zu
kalt ja wohl darum diese oben station um
genauer und das ist der dienstraum von
robert schad hier beobachten er und
seine kollegen das wetter und sie kennen
natürlich auch den wetterbericht sie
somit 21 grad für heute maximum
angegeben das ist auch das gleiche bei
mir würde also berichte erhängen und da
ist so haben wir auch die vorhersage
ebenso also dass die heute sonnig mit
temperaturen im tal bis 21 grad
auf dem gipfel ist es sehr viel kälter
dafür können die drei bei diesem wetter
aber über 100 kilometer weit sehen
vorgestern noch das anders
es war schneefall 15 cm neuschnee hat
sich hier das wetter geändert mit der
klimawandel
ja es hat durchaus gene die letzten
25 jahre ist gut erkennbar dass die idee
die temperaturen ansteigen sind und der
gletscher unten ist auch die letzten
jahrzehnte schwer zurückkommen
die wetterstation ist sogar noch etwas
höher als der zugspitz gipfel
das sind also fotos vom allerhöchsten
platz deutschlands aufgelöst
und da gibt es jetzt das erste ticket
damit geht team süd mit dem ersten
ticket in führung
berlin
ich will
sie nicht